and we're live we're live everybody
welcome to episode 30 over and cafe
episode 30 hard to believe it's already
episode 30 and when we first started
this show it was we were at about 2,000
subscribers and now we are celebrating
twenty thousand subscribers everybody
thank you so much welcome to the party
we're gonna be chilling tonight having
fun celebrating with all of you who made
this possible thank you so much we
actually have goes in making his first
appearance on Rann cafe because of
course he's gotta clean on my first oh I
don't think it's my first appearance but
we had to it first in rent copay believe
me without technical difficulties but
yeah and this is basically we have to
have him on because he's obviously these
other part of this channel I've been
working so hard on the attack with Titan
videos that I've been getting so much
support so we have to have goes on in
here
and of course we have anime recon
cyanide blizzard is back after a bit of
a hiatus due to ness in real life
all-day anime is here and perhaps we'll
get to Mac Tony coming in later we'll
see but yeah guys this is gonna be a
real chill party time just you know
getting drunk drinking coffee spiked
with ROM whatever you you like I don't
drink
recon your look choice I don't want a
van especially it said in the indirect
effect contract it clearly says if Anna
Mac tells you to drink you have to do it
I'm afraid I don't drink any Mac so I
can't force you don't have to do it
after an cafe but during rank up faith I
tell you it's you got to reread your
contract medicine man I've water I can
do water oh you know h2o is way fun
diamond what give me a shot of this h2o
we know there's a Google get a water
bottle filled with vodka it was like
what why would you bring that the school
and was on a Monday to Wow if you live
in life he's living the good life yeah
he's like hey the party's still going
I'm like okay guys look at yeah the
Chad's going off the hook we got
forgotten 915 girl bro
harutora or Haruko
Naruto tora tora tora dance I like I
like renunciation active on this one I
move Dora
dude we have Luna of course a luna gosh
Ryan lump king lump Kings to win free
rap bro he know is there Ino says go
quick for non weaves is roar nook stalk
you actually just dropped his rap ten
minutes ago I didn't even notice I'm
waiting to laugh hearted guy to drop it
because I oh yeah that's gonna be great
I'm waiting I said I was just in a
stream black Rick I said tomorrow next
week he's dropping his rap knocks Taku
just dropped but I haven't even had time
to see it so I can't wait cuz I feel
like I feel like he'll be good I was a
trained eye also attack the enemy dude I
don't know if you guys know him Briggs
you my good old yeah yeah he said yeah I
was attacked him to do it so you said
he's gonna do it he's been on one of the
Cody s teams on this shadow actually
yeah yeah we're we're tight with the
anime dude we're tight
hey welcome everyone who's here of
course again if you're new to the
channel and you don't know what rank of
a is this is a weekly podcast that we do
every Thursday at 5 p.m. Eastern Time
where we talk about all sorts of anime
topics and a bunch of other youtubers
fellow youtubers and this one is special
because we're celebrating 20k having a
party chilling out relaxing all that
stuff that I just need bless you thank
you it's also old ones first time here
so can you both bro although I guess cuz
of time differences yeah old when you're
in Spain right españa we uh by the way I
don't care what anyone in Spain says
it's Valencia not Valencia okay lens
yeah
Ibiza not Ibiza okay guys sorry
[Music]
so which we what we're gonna talk about
today let's do something fun yeah man
are you waiting man I don't know what do
you guys wanna talk about well let me
know on the channel what do you guys
planning you have to 20k actually keep
talking on their knees and stuff man
like yeah well I'm gonna definitely keep
up with the attack on Titan videos and
then we'll see we'll see from there
we're gotta get into obviously see if we
can get into some other popular shows to
catch up on other Piper shows and yeah
shout out to Dylan shout out to Nick
victory fire Josh Daphne's a regular low
Bester al or Al remember him bro
remember him goes and he's he's been
here since under 1k I remember this guy
caster Josh stuff here
I'm a yo-yo yo-yo and yeah a lump King
waiting for that rap man yes great great
time and we're definitely gonna be doing
the attacking time videos still but we I
have some other stuff planned for a
bunch of other anime that I've and and
just like a general anime stuff that
we've been kind of saving up for the
summer when we have more time and now
that both goes on and I have time we're
gonna be getting into those they're
gonna be a lot more content coming out
of the chunk even skits we have a skit
in the work in the works parts of which
we filmed at anime North Briggs knows he
was there so yeah I'm looking forward to
rapping again guys I'll just shout out
to wait for next week you're gonna sorry
you're not to wait for next year
well he can rap on my for no one I don't
like tell you currently oh wait till you
get time it's like the good feeling get
tagged like oh yeah we got time time to
do this [ __ ] let's go
I accept challenges you know exactly
know what you got you came back down you
get tagged you got a goal you got a goal
no but I think up what's up yeah I think
I know what the best thing we should do
we should do an anime rap battle and see
who is the hottest taco rapper within
ran cafe you mean well
please don't bail right now no no you
can find it out like an actual video
we free we do like a rap battle and then
ya make a compilation to the rap we
already did
double people in one video let's just
let's just do it
well the other side the wins
actually yes that's a good idea since
we've already made our rap videos we can
put it all together into a video into a
single video and then people get to
decide who rap the best I mean I mean
the people know it's me but I mean if
you guys want I just want to say lump
King says he's been here since seven
hundred subscribers I didn't even know
that's that's the case man that's
awesome thanks for sticking with us that
like it's always great to get new
supporters but it's always great to you
know to know people who have been here
for a long time and are like still
sticking with you meaning that you
didn't bore them to death so that's
awesome
oh thanks Arthur ooh howdy taro just
said that your rap was really good thank
you at least some people appreciate what
I do it
I like the UN and I like that I
appreciate what you do I just think I'm
the fan right I just think I'm the best
see there we go you can't deny that I
mean yeah I mean have you guys have you
guys not notice that I think I'm the
best by now I mean I mean boy his name
is climbing up backwards from the very
first moment you don't have the spirits
of common with the new Your Honor
malcomson
yeah exactly I have this nose around
that's the ultimate insult there when I
said I Spit these lyrics in the spirit
of calm unibrow that's what I won and me
rap like the mic was just dropped anime
recon is great cuz he takes you on a
journey you know he was like
illustrating what he's doing with like
reminisce it was just great yeah you're
the king with all the harem body
people's alumnus yeah when I said met a
girl with silver hair and called herself
a hassle
[Laughter]
oh it was good it was good oh by the way
cyanide bro cyanide you have done an
ASMR video I think I pretty sure you can
do a rap video man well I actually got
some news for you guys I'm gonna be
stepping down from my channel actually
know what
I yeah my schedule is picking up I'm
actually going back to school gonna go
into project management redirecting my
degree so yeah I'm actually gonna be
stepping down full-time student
part-time work stuff I'll still be
around still gonna be here for Rand cafe
I click sadly I'm stepping down so
cyanides what about us I thought you're
gonna say I'm stepping down for my
channel to become a full-time rapper oh
I wish man I wish cyanide what about us
what about the things that we've talked
about you on Twitter you don't remember
if they don't remember all the things
that we've talked about why you wrote
them so you just broke my heart don't
cry for me Argentina by the way the
pumpkins only hope is in the Chad shout
out to him imperialist opinion his
pinions is there as well and Eric's
agario says just a period he just put a
period and I feel like that says a lot
he commented on the US radio - it's very
philosophical he just put a period knobs
this year what's up nubs
no Josh Bachman why do I own when you
didn't comment on my calling out Spanish
pronunciation from Spain you probably
couldn't you Pro like man [ __ ] Anna Mac
but did not say anything son let's just
turn it out after a while man we're just
tilling it out I guess I guess so but
yeah man it's really been insane these
last few weeks
so much support so much you know hard
work paying off in terms of you know
people actually recognizing it starting
little channel Hochstein isn't charity
and clothes then you've been doing an
amazing job man working hard ever ever
since girls in finishes cool stuff you
guys remember he by the way don't
activate anything yeah we've been doing
good he graduated so congrats to go then
on that he got two degrees one education
hmm and one in English so he now
officially speaks English
congratulations
how good and I can finally speak English
and they just let me teach her right
away in high schools - yeah knocks talk
who's in the chat and he says he
he did the drop the rap and he's
thanking me for tagging him yes bro we
haven't I haven't seen the rap yet
because I actually started streaming
right as as the I got the notification
but I can't wait to check that out
knocks I tagged you because I knew you'd
be good you're hilarious your videos are
really funny so I knew that your rap
would be hilarious as well and we got to
get you in on one of these rant cafe
episodes if you're down to stream let me
know we got to come up with a fun topic
and get you in because I just I feel
like Knox is just a funny interesting
guy man that make for a great Rand cafe
gotta say it's true it is true people
naively Superman is congratulating us
and brawl where's black Critic guy I saw
you I know your mod on his channel get
him in here get him in here point is
that you constantly hitting the mic or
what that would probably bring yeah stop
hitting the mic Reap I don't think I am
but like it's always made a perilous it
is man basically it's Briggs whatever
how so sensitive it's ridiculously
sensitive I even have our own Stan
that's what you guys hear that
yeah it's like you're hitting on your
desk instead of your mic not even
touching but yeah I don't know it just
sounds like you're banging on a desk
instead of your wife I think it's my
chair my chairs lot of thing you know
sometimes you hit the table accidentally
and it the mic picks it up yeah I'm
trying not to hit anything so hopefully
it will it's not me tell Levin says dude
you're a OT are awesome thank you I
appreciate that
I'm hold alt all of it bro they've got
the support on those videos does bit
insane like I can't even like it's like
a dream no lie people saying we deserve
like millions of subs and stuff like
that like you guys are crazy
are you the only one who works on these
videos alone uh actually all we just got
from Gilgamesh two two bucks Thank You
Gilgamesh shout out to Gilgamesh is
Mexican Spanish in this game I'm a I'm a
fan of Colombian Spanish my
self because I've been that's the one
I've been most exposed to but you know
to each his own each is own apparently
got a theory idea for an attack contain
video that we'll do sometime soon yes
yes goes in I wrote a script for a video
that talks about I'm one of the biggest
mysteries so yeah we probably shouldn't
saying good money rather than bring your
jugular shitless this mystery the based
on it it's like it's the origins of
everything and I have a theory that ties
in the origins of that whole world the
new opening with those dinosaurs and
[ __ ] like it's all tied in together guys
and it's all going to come together in
that video look out for that we're gonna
probably sometime next week be dropping
that right goes on people I don't know
about that but we'll see we'll see I'm
extremely excited your personal requests
right now there's so many requests right
now for people that we're trying to
figure out everything we do we can't
keep going like three videos a week but
we'll do our best so you heard it here
next week is how it's happening we'll
see cousin are you the only one who
works on these it's a alt videos like it
they're there mainly yes
then what does Adamek do does he because
it does this stuff bro as you like rest
in bed and just watches you work like he
actually helped me out yesterday was
doing some stuff around the house so I
could grind all night and actually
finish that 26 minute video that we
published today 26 minutes I mean that
was that killed me well I've been you
fair adamak held the channel on his back
while you were in school it was true red
is true no doubt
gappy what's up bro gabby is a dude he's
an interesting dude II I don't know if
he found us from the snob animated snobs
videos or if he found us through um DX
fans video but he he was he like made a
response talking about my response to
the Code Geass thing and then I was like
man nice response and it was like you
know what bro I'm gonna start following
you guys channel so we
like frenemies but like he's a cool dude
but goes and make your own channel I'll
fling the host
listen post these videos for yourself a
lot of people will notice you know man
it's cool I don't need the credit I just
I just want I just want the channa me up
for her to do well bro like check out
the first videos I did like three years
ago
they're like am bees and stuff I never
thought I could like actually get money
any money you did am these before yeah
yeah check it out really it the earliest
videos in this channel is just me
messing around with I am bees bro yeah
good stuff actually definitely we're
checking out BC if you're onto something
recon I think we need to have an art if
you will the story of anime uproar they
think Anna Mac goes in they work
together they rise to the stars but one
day strife interferes and suddenly there
splits it goes no their separate ways
until one day when they're reunited and
they combine their powers one common
enemy and is that enemy digi bro
probably if you want it to be but no the
thing about anime operates it's you know
even the name it's not like an
individual name it's the name of a team
so it's always been goes in and I and
now we feel like all our fans are part
of that team and we're like a
conglomerate we're at like dying Oren
right that's a side room like it's a
team it's not an individual person
it's like die good not like seven so let
me ask you this do you
the Gozen does Anna Mac share his
revenue with you it's not his revenue
it's it's our revenue yeah it's our
opera is our thing so it's always been
like it's something like I think people
assume that it's just me because I was
gonna appear on camera when Gozen was at
school but it's always been the to us
and even when he was in school you were
still helping me with with editing like
I was always saying you're not helping
me enough grow but he was still helping
me with editing so yeah he's disguise
crazy like literally doing to two
degrees earning two degrees at once and
this guy's like all my back every day
when I come home
Rosanne who's crazy now 20k saw blood
who's crazy here's the deal
an AK was pushing you to be the best you
possibly could because he's like I see
the potential in you I want you to rise
to the occasion you were just lucky I'm
alive right now after all that work
right all right
Oh since you two owned the channel anime
uproar I think it's time for a name
change you know someone's not now
something that fits between the both of
you I mean Anna Mike and goes and figure
out a good name really kerberion love
getting up for never gonna change it
yeah I love recon yo now that you guys
are doing really well and growing
quickly you should actually come up with
a good name like nom economy up or is a
bad name which let's say like thinking
for good names let's just think about
what do you think you would call
yourselves if you to like diffusion
together to just just imagine drivable
animail but you bro that's the whole
point
Adam upper would be hassle we have
omelet with urea tank your name's not
looking at with your name's Adam I can
never go back is another one cause it
goes the Mac is good oh yeah like goes
it was a necessity goes a Mac Lucas like
if the name has changed he's unsub and
on't worry the name will not change
Orabrush we had that name before we had
an American goals then we had anime
uproars not me yeah exactly anime uproar
was we came up with in the basement
before we even like we're like hey man
we're gonna like actually make regular
videos or just like anime up for sounds
cool yeah man yeah but no it's been just
insane and awesome and yeah we're really
happy that people are actually
discovering the channel and our videos
because we were making videos back in
the day when like we would get off we
get a hundred two hundred usually were
happy and like a lot of work would go
into them and a lot of work still goes
into the videos but we were just really
humbled and happy that much much more
people are now actually watching them
and appreciating them and yeah it's it's
a great feeling and I feel like both
goals and I have been working hard
and it's been a great time that we got
to meet all you awesome peeps fellow
youtubers well people who come here and
hang out with us every day every week
regularly on rent cafe and in other
streams and watching the videos it's
just been crazy love it love it yeah
yeah we used to put in like we do we
still put a lot of work but literally we
used to spend like a week doing a comedy
skit like doing multiple takes putting
it all together and like if we got over
a thousand views in a week we'd be like
whoo that's crazy right so I like to
remember those times when we're like you
know like tight times like this where
we're doing like way better than we were
at that point now you expect that 1k in
a day right yeah least bro no it's true
though like I remember the first video I
did that hit a hundred views I was
freaking out like way back and know that
you know you should look at your views
and you're like oh this is this terrible
it compared to myself count why normally
good around this time she's a lot more
critical about it yeah it's that feeling
when you put everything together you're
trying to feel it all out and when it
finally comes together and it does
actually take off then you just like
you're just you're just know exactly man
Rock the end if you actually like the
other day we have I think 88,000 views
in one day or something like that like
not on one video but like all together
and that's just insane like you can't
even think about like 88,000 people
watching your videos in one day like
that's just like it's not even like
you're getting a really grasp dad
concept it's very long so yeah it's just
really really humbling yeah yeah it's
cool but I have a question for you both
actually I mean with 20k here obviously
you're still humble you remember your
foundation your roots but what does the
future hold for anime uproar like I've
noticed for your video there's an anime
up or a shirt we can start seeing more
merch available with what's going on
that would be cool but we don't really
know how to go about it man we don't we
don't know we don't have the
infrastructure we don't know what to do
what do you mean
to [ __ ] sell merch just create a
website yes I don't know how to do that
well we're definitely if people are
interested in people do keep asking us
about shirts and stuff we are gonna look
into it because you guys keep asking for
it to make sure it's available and stuff
like that for people who want to buy
them and obviously that way you're
getting something actually also
supporting the channel directly which is
awesome but we have to figure out you
know how to actually have people be able
to pre-order and then we know how many
to make and that and how to deliver it
because you know delivery it especially
if it's like far away like to Asia and
stuff can cost more than the actual
product so then we would have to weigh
over like you know charge people way too
much for a shirt or something and we
don't want to do that so you have to
ground how to do any not not brigs like
everybody's wearing the shirts
oh nice regs representative I completely
forgot I feel like telling myself I'm
gonna wear on stream and you guys had to
trigger that like yeah that's wise you
like a shirt bro and it's a good fit
yeah you got the medium like you put
your your channel logo on the shirt as
well that would we did oh did you it's
it's hidden within the manga ask page at
the front boom it's on a laptop in space
bro no no it's not laptop wait yeah this
is it oh [ __ ] yeah I mean they don't
believe you didn't see that Rico oh no
sir I just show the dogs like no I
didn't even notice that let's see it
that's the thing it's like it's like a
good story you see more of it when you
see on second time it's subtle it's got
yep ladies laptop I'm faced with the
logo of anime Oh fair enough me and my
buddy we're actually talking when he
designed the shirts
bojay shoutout to him and we were in my
basement where boom boy and his right
more Anna Mack is right now and we were
like he was like oh man like so what are
you looking for I'm like you know I'll
be cool and I grabbed another tool manga
and like bro like let's do it in the
style of a manga page man and then
that's what came out of Italy it's like
our own story kind of within a manga
page so it's like
don't know great idea I catchy that's
what you want so uh very well done job
on the design there got to say they
don't forget to design the Anna Mac body
pillow yeah luna luna at isaac i would
buy an animal I feel like believe in
body pillows I think that's awesome like
I can have an MST honest an a damag body
could be great for fangirls uh-huh I'm
not gonna have one but if I did what
poster I'd do some like this like a sexy
pose oh yes
you gotta go like this and then like
flexpa pretend like I'm not flexing you
know like great big cat Cataldo my elbow
no what what you need to do is have
someone hold the camera up high like an
immaculate Ben goes and goes like
standing on the bed just takes a like a
white shot of you doing a pose and then
you just design the body pump easy as
that man this is getting so weird I
don't know what's happening I don't know
why do I on one side goes it on the
other you know all right
Wow why do I get dragged into it why the
hell you know you made it bro don't know
what goals animals you know what goes on
says like no man cuz I would have to be
a bigger pillow because I'm so much
taller that's what he'll say yeah would
have to be a different size Phil uh I'm
actually there there's the other there
is a long like the longest body pillow
I've ever seen was actually um mommy oh
yeah Mia from Monster Newsome it has the
longest body pillow I've ever seen I
know you're going with that by the way
shout out to ghost stalker and amelia in
the chat shout-out to Sufjan as well he
just says hello d almari says hello
[ __ ] hello bro but what I wanted to
say actually I was watching the latest
Aki Dearest video and she got like from
a company they sent her a body pillow of
the armored Titan and look it hilarious
like like the armored Titan body pillow
it looks so funny who wants to hug an
armored Titan hey don't knock
don't knock J you tried it yeah man I
mean if it was a rider then yeah it was
writer himself it'll be nice yeah but it
was
at the big ass armored Titan yeah a
little bit weird I'm over armored Titan
guy myself I'm high I'm more of a Prius
guy I love I love the female Titan um in
the manga I don't know I don't remember
now if it was in the anime but in the
manga when Armin is talking to Ray uh
Reiner and he's like yo you just see
that um abnormal Titan and he's like oh
the one with the nice ass okay dad yeah
female Titan body pillow everybody is it
addressed me as an attack on Titan have
like a poorly drawn manga ify I read
like five chapters today it a lot of
people have son it gets better but holy
crap like the Monda recent illustrations
have been so good like I just I'm in
love with the man yeah I personally
don't mind the drawings because I feel
like the Titans are supposed to be drawn
weird
they're supposed to be drawn in a
awkward uncanny way in order to kind of
make you feel more like weirded out by
the concept of these Titans so you don't
get kind of like comfortable with them
existing it's kind of like every time
you see them drawn in such a weird human
yet not human way you're like oh man
nuts well that's a messed up world so I
feel like and I agree but then you like
how the one Big Sky to eyeball can put a
few up they made them up weirdest [ __ ] I
wouldn't care I just like they're like
positions that they're like I don't know
I haven't read the manga until like
today I read like couple chapters I was
curious and I watched our reading
because sadly it's coming to an end
right I was like I was so like taken
back by barely even the human faces like
the tide of heightened okay like the
weirdness is all right I've heard it
gets it gets better and like I agree
with that but at the same time it never
I've never thought like you like hey
this is bad like it never took me Adam
never I always could suspend my
disbelief and that was never like oh man
this is so bad I can't focus yeah to me
it's not it's it's not the start
like I don't I don't mind it I don't
like ya not I hadn't I hadn't read it I
came from like such a well like
animating and naik are styled anime and
I went to that I didn't expect it
well like the one-piece fan I like it's
the exact opposite I like I watched the
anime and it kind of sucks and then I go
and read the mag on my wallet this
artworks amazing alright we all know
that in two days time and it's gonna be
the end of attack on Titan but rest in
peace I pretty much know there will be a
third season because the story behind
the beast Titan is not yet and is not
yet you know there can't no they're
definitely get out like attack on Titan
is definitely gonna be animated fully
it's just yeah we don't know how long
we'll have to wait that's you and for
your faith convoy is going to say that
we're probably directory and get more
shape we're probably gonna have to wait
maybe an extra four to four years for
you know what for a potential third
season which is gonna suck yeah but
Cameron well I don't I think in terms of
material they definitely have enough
material for another season definitely
for another 12 episode season probably
even for another 25 but it all depends
how they want to do it right however I'm
definitely hoping that they're not gonna
make us wait another three or four years
I'm doing some research on that right
now about how soon we can expect of
season three so you know stay tuned I
lost something coming up Jenna regard
but yeah I think in terms of you know
with attackin I there's no issues with
popularity or finance no you know be
profitable so they could definitely do
it and if you look at my hero academia
they had the first 12 episode season
last year and within a year they already
have a 25 episode second season so it's
doable and if that's not that's not a
low-budget anime either right so it's
doable no they're gonna do it it's just
yeah like right now we're gonna have to
just be patient and read the monthly
mountain manga installments right and
then wait until the anime comes out and
by the way Tony is supposedly on his way
within three minutes he should be coming
in thanks Philly Superman also also a
soul maka in the chat was like is
all-day anime the one piece fanboys
serious
complaining about art styles is he
serious oh I'm in love with older czars
oh you're not talking about no like
that's the big red that was nice get me
where I was like holy [ __ ] this is
bothering me do not within the series of
äôt I'm just waiting for them better
hold to get some of that any ass oh man
yeah very exactly but if a really good
point is that most the time when you
jump from the manga to the anime that's
generally when you're gonna see a change
most notably a decrease in quality of
the artworks but because animations a
lot more costly so of course then they
minimalize things to make it ease of use
for animation so when you go from
something like attack on Titan which
really had a good look to when you first
start off with the manga which it does
get a lot better as goes instead it
trims art style I read like of the first
hundred chapters or so before it stopped
I mean that's just it it is a bit
jarring at first that's actually a
really good thing because we almost kind
of condition ourselves mentally to
expect the manga to be better you're
using one piece was a fantastic example
there you know especially for a
long-running series that I didn't a
thought it looks great yet night/day
exactly so that that's kind of a big
thing is especially when you do start
off with an anime and you go to the
manga it does kind of throw you off
especially because attack on Titan was
done so well so well Easter holiday put
there for you they're there for years to
good use right yeah shout out to
Terminator G even new in the checkpoint
area so it's up blader
blader Inc welcome guys to rant cafe the
sickest podcast in town but yeah first
in terms of animation
attackin time season 2 has been great I
just the CGI stuff like with the
colossal type make you make too big a
deal out of it I really think the CGI is
with the closet line is a bit jarring it
kind of takes your it's like oh man that
CGI but otherwise definitely nothing to
complain about I love how they animate
the vertical maneuvering gears of
sequences those are amazing for sure
which what CGI for the colossal timing
talk about
are you talking about when they
transform he's talking about
specifically I think a scene where he's
moving his arms slowly to like kind of
sweep the top of the wall and because
they wanted to like illustrate how slow
it is and how colossal he is that they
did it in like that
CG is Quay cause I didn't find any
problems with the CGI of the cost of
time and I thought it was good even
really needed like even when I was at a
drink
I mean even when I reacts to the episode
itself I was like okay I don't know why
people are hating all of a sudden on the
CGI the claws go Tainan I decided you
know what I'm just gonna defend it I'm
gonna say it's really good cuz I feel
like there's only no flaws exactly I
didn't really [ __ ] care look I'm
gonna make a deal I'm just saying it's
always who hello hello whatever going
nice to meet you in person always call
me the block critic guy what's up Tony
hello hello and right a lot of people
were on my other livestream saying
weren't you over at the data a tomato
for subscribers that's hilarious hahaha
it's a gay stop I need your old
livestream get Austin yeah like I need
tell them to do that Tony I promise I
didn't you know when you say stuff like
that you incriminate yourself and a Mac
I thought you were I thought you have a
PhD you're smarter than that
when are you dropping in Austin yeah but
it's not like you're gonna bother to go
back and listen to me telling people
specifically to tell you to come here
you have no idea of the levels the
levels of dedication I will go through
to hear something no clue
they are astronomical I mean I would
have liked a star cast right now I just
want to say that we have a lot of
youtubers there but there's no there's
no Mackel not we cannot never show polar
he is I'm Claudia joy everyone's invited
to the 20k subs party this is what we
party bro everyone's welcome everyone's
invited chatting having a good time
no one's no one's doing a freestyle
battle rap yet it's great it's a great
time by the way say this to anime recon
C's been pushing me when is your mixtape
coming out oh I want to hear your rap
for once for once but I have not even
heard
you rock I've wrapped before trust me
I'm telling you I'm telling you right
now you rap you might have sounded
different back then but I want to hear
the new you the new me the new Mia honey
you're the new you I'm telling you right
now though I finished writing it and it
is pretty it's pretty nasty
it's a I go really wrong I'm not I'm not
I'm not even exaggerating it's is it is
it as nasty as nasty nas the ESCO to
Escobar now he is Nostradamus I mean I'm
not I'm not ever gonna compare myself to
yeah not good good move good I'm sucking
up not gonna compare myself to that guy
we talked about nastier I mean how's
your Jones untouched one of the best
your Jones baby see my man you know what
actual hip hop is which a lot of people
don't NAS AZ that's the crew that I met
from you know how you gotta start your
stuff Tony you gotta start your rap oh
hey man I don't know how to start this
[ __ ] no no no yo you'll love the way in
fact you actually will get a snippet of
it real soon I'm probably gonna upload 8
5 second teaser to the song on Saturday
did you crash about bail on such hype
sub hype awesome now the reason the
reason it's taking so long is because
I'm actually gonna one-up all of you and
make a music video to the rap oh oh oh
wait what does that mean what do you
mean I know what it means
it's a music video what do you think it
means oh you're doing a music video okay
that's gonna be great
that's my gosh so you're actually gonna
show yourself while you're rapping that
was that one okay that's good about that
I can't wait no he's gonna make like a
video that goes along with it sort of
like how certain bands have Envy's so
basically that's it he's doing it to go
along with that I gotta feel it himself
but yeah like funny sides just drawing
like a girl's butt well he's like you
know funny enough I will be showing a
part of a girl but it isn't her but
that's that's weird on it so it was
random
and the rap videos gonna be good it's
gonna be good it's around their rules
though the rap is not only like dis
track - all of my contemporaries it's a
diss track on enemy especially a certain
genre of enemy I swear if he talks with
the one piece I'm finding you in there
I'm gonna drop some yah yah yah you know
I might have to go back I might have to
go back and rewrite some things yes Tony
dude I hope you should talked about
Amelia because that's what I want to
hear oh don't worry
oh yeah my rap I don't listen Ram
there's really there's there's a line it
notice three lines actually once
dedicated to Amelia which is actually
goes alongside with Adam AK and there's
a line dedicated to you recon yeah I
don't know man he's hyping it up so much
I might have to do a response to his
response I might have never have to do a
discord I'm actually excited is the
title I want I'm excited to see how
people will react to it again like I
said it's pretty nasty even I was like
dad oh pretty or damn I don't know Tony
about Tony cuz I always felt that you
ain't a crook son yeah you know I'm not
sure you know yes we'll see we'll see I
love it I will turn shade him you know
it's funny I that was the the beat to
that song was in the top three that I
was going to pick ya shook once part two
man that beat man that's one of those
one of those beats man you can't you
can't replicate it again it's a it's
hard it's tough rhythmically it's
beautiful maybe it's good it's a great B
or um did you guys see the Black Panther
trailer I haven't but I saw I was
trending on YouTube I saw that it was
rented for two days straight
how crazy is that yeah like 30 million
views or something crazy yeah the song
that they use on the train
I was going to use that beat um by the
way Briggs I need to hear you I need to
see your rep I saw I saw Anna Mac I saw
enemy recon I was surprised to see that
freaking DG bro did one too did he
actually won last year I won last year
he didn't do wonder this year
wait that was from last year oh yeah you
don't get one this year
yes last year the enemy man did did one
doe so now I guess I'm I thought that
was from this year cuz I'm like oh [ __ ]
I didn't know [ __ ] dizzy brownie was
getting into this game to Tony I want to
collab with you I want to do a rap
battle me and you versus an American
Briggs we will officially beat their ass
oh come on man what do you think by the
way shout out to Alberto productions he
really likes his emojis especially the
poop emoji so I just want to acknowledge
him oh also deep voice a case Norley is
in the house even though it's like
almost midnight Maria's is in the house
always supporting anime opera always
part of the team appreciated bro what by
the way by the way can I just take the
time to just admire how well you've been
doing at a Mac like I just noticed you
started doing these explained videos and
like you've been blowing up like [ __ ]
crazy dog probably broke oh I have to I
have to say though most of those videos
is gozen is behind the screen oh goes in
you're the one that made videos yeah bro
yeah oh wait are you his brother right
you're the brothers yeah I noticed the
voice oh [ __ ] yeah we sound familiar
yeah that's why I could take credit but
I don't
so it so goes in makes the tackle tying
videos and then you make all the other
ones yeah for now
well either way though you guys are a
team just like nodes in a stout-hearted
you know anime awkward is going the team
of two brothers that's right exactly
it's an animal purrs always been the two
of us we started together we've been
doing it together sometimes he's busier
so then I pick up the slack sometimes
I'm busier he picks up the slack but
it's always been a team and yeah it's
been great the only thing is that rant
cafe goes and usually hasn't been coming
here so you some of you guys don't home
but
he's always helping and even when we
were doing like you know the long code
geass videos the complex ones even
though I do the script and like record
he would still help me edit because
there was a lot of editing work to do so
yeah we've always been a team and that's
that's the best one
yeah the best part the best part was
when he like he likes thanks he thanks
like everyone at the end but that
doesn't mention me like it's my oh by
the way caster for life says we're the
Elric brothers of YouTube I like that oh
one of the tall one I'm Tamara I'm the
younger taller it's my role there for a
sec I would all talk except I would also
accept the Daft Punk of anime but other
elders like down there so now your order
and a mac communist backwards when I
used to like C Mon backwards I know I
like I like that one I like that punk of
anime yeah it's a slow down there okay
slow down this person I think it'd be
it'd be more fair to say that you guys
are the RAM and RAM of the I want to be
not I want to be nos so only one of them
is I see your own oh I heard that I
heard that brick gets like that from me
Wow let's go by the way
shout out to sin of code I see them on
the discord all the time how's it going
bro and if you don't know that we have a
discord where that's really active we
have a lot of people there were there
all the time chatting uh
it's in the link is in the description
you can always join us you know we don't
make videos every day however on this
chord you can chat every day get the
latest news every day it's always a fun
time I love being there hanging out
there and tonight definitely parting on
this chord hanging out voice chatting
it's gonna happen guys it's gonna happen
so what would make you guys start doing
the whole explained videos for the times
and stuff I'm curious cuz that came out
of nowhere I didn't see the commercial
actually came up with the idea when I
was still finishing my degrees so I just
finished Teachers College and I came up
with the idea I told Adam AK for the
first one was every tight and explain
and then he's like oh yeah I may write
that down like we gotta do that so that
I actually did it like the same week we
posted it as I finished like I finished
my hand
all the last high school papers that day
and then we published it and then that
video was doing like a thousand views a
day which was good so we kept the
momentum going and like yes
no like the smiling Titan explained did
how much in a day and iMac like what was
it like 50,000 km a thousand in one day
4,000 unexplained in the first day
50,000 men yeah so Dallas that was just
all like crying almost like a thousand
man oh I think I I think I speak for
everyone here when I say [ __ ] you know
but the way the idea really came to is
goes a night together came up with the
idea to do what every toss video back in
the day I offer my cutting off I don't
know why right now look there it's good
now that yeah so we started off with
every Geass explained video
whose idea was that every Geass power
explained goals that we came up with the
idea together I was all I wanted to I
wanted to talk about everything we know
about Geass power and you said why don't
we then also talk about every Geass
power that we know of
fine teamwork all right it was teamwork
and then you still have doing awesome
that video is great that video did well
so then we were thinking later arm you
know what about Heath goes on top
lockers so we have every years explained
and then pretty well it's like 75
thousand right now we use what if we did
every Titan explain I was like oh man
that's a great idea because you know you
know attack on Titan it's a great show
like again code yes a show we love
attack on Titan a show we love so we
were again why not like that would be
something that we would enjoy doing for
we yeah goes and it and he had other
ideas
and then I had other ideas to who is the
strongest Titan it was my idea to so
calls in you know credit are you are you
both people to come up with those ideas
to do like explain videos for like um
every study every night and explain
video no I think the person even YouTube
is ever like yeah it like so there are
very I plain let me just look at Sinai
blizzard he's the most copycat of all of
us
your story no really I mean I just
looked at what was available out there
and I was like what can I do how can I
do it and how can I mix things up a
little bit changed a few things for
Goldy the beauty of what the the
animatic Bros did is they found an offer
to animate author or prose let me
correct you
yes the enemy up grows um the beauty of
what they did was that they found a
market that was right for the taking is
I don't think there were a lot of um
explained videos for the tie-ins and all
this stuff that while it detail and it
was a very smart move especially at a
time where you know attack on time is
quite relevant and they they found the
opportunity took it that's what you're
supposed to do you know I'm trying yeah
and I'm the other thing is again we feel
wildly deja vu we're just blessed that
inanimate we actually really a lot of
and mana is what we can make videos on
that people like us for because we
wouldn't want to make you know videos
and something that we don't necessarily
like like tokyo ghoul sorry talkie one
fans but we're not yeah we're not big
fans of that so we wouldn't want to do
that just because people are watching it
and we don't love it so we want to
combine what we love and hopefully get
you know people actually enjoying our
videos because when you love something
and you're doing it it comes out like
people know okay you're passionate about
this you love this like it you they can
tell so that's important ah [ __ ]
mario64 a great name yeah I just miss
moriata
he said it on me he said he felt special
because we loved his common good for him
and you you are special isn't that kind
of funny isn't that kind of funny he
says he feels special with that oh it's
for music but tomorrow 64 is on every
video it's awesome thanks for the
support bro yeah thank you for support
and also he's asking is one punch man
season 2 coming in November of this year
I haven't heard this I know one punch
man season 2 is officially in production
it's confirmed 100% but we don't have a
release date yet last time I checked
I'll actually go check right now on the
extra special Japanese great it's not it
doesn't have a release date yeah
you're Briggs you know we got a do right
we got a do we got a deuce item I
explain videos I know but literally a
mother cannot start thinking about the
name guys do you know like sorry we're
gonna explain everything
liyan explained where we're orders I'm a
power come from X I mean I know most of
you here to explain video specifically
for the anime uh pro team and YouTube
regs but for me I want to grow doing top
tens as well I wanna find I love doing
that top tens and onna fine know exactly
like you said Tony find the market
exactly that fits me can I give you a
suggestion then yes please go ahead top
that incest anime Oh what no that will
get views trust me I will give you look
at any block critic guy incest anime
review it's off the charts
it's off the charts because I'm angry
hello my suggestion
my suggestion is this drop the top in
your top ten and make it 10 like maybe
10 facts about 10 things about you know
like that's something that I've noticed
um the ideal the top 10 has slowly died
on YouTube I've seen this on like
WatchMojo which has been been declining
for months or for years now because they
just be suck but I've seen anime a kind
of like um 2spooky and what he does that
most other channels do too is they don't
put the word top they say 10 facts or 20
facts or 5 facts you know like straight
to the point without making it like a
ranking system but information that they
can obtain you know I'm saying I'm as
wafer you still generate this discussion
with the master I like I like recommend
I like rank the anime mmm-hmm well I
don't know I'm not really a fact person
who gives out information so what I mean
by running by dropping an anime
no go ahead but it's like you could do
like yeah you could just do like 10
anime like hey I of the harem genre or
like they could figure out a way to word
it without putting top in front I
actually started doing that but then all
my videos it [ __ ] I don't know why I
went back to doing top 10
see I'm the opposite man I I did the
whole top ten I realized man they're not
getting the views I want I start doing
again for one video I did um ten good
characters and bad anime and I did that
video did more successfully than my top
10 anime couples and I was I don't know
whether it's because I was talking about
a bad anime or no because of the or the
talk at the thing is singing octave if
they come into play it's so hard and
like trying to figure out what was it is
not is not it doesn't go with a Ty Lee
you can put top ten you can put ten it
doesn't really matter the fact is they
need to try and get your video node as a
title itself doesn't matter I've seen a
lot of youtubers out there put top ten
uh they're very limited people who put
ten harem anime shit-shit-shit look
there's this so that's how you
differentiate yourself because
everyone's doing top ten in the top ten
community right later Steve that up and
that's that's the thing that the bring
up is really interesting so a few years
back a friend of mine was talking to
misty connection and he was very
interested in expanding his content
because he thinking to get ahead of the
curve because he knew that some point
lists are going to be phased out they
are it's just it's it's a been
eventualities thing comes in cycles so
it's helping reinvent something or how
can you freshen it up to stay ahead of
the curve so the thing is that yes there
are still our top ten lists that do get
a ton of views but it is a bit on the
decline it's been for like the past two
years in certain aspects there are still
plenty of videos out there that do hit a
lot of views but it's not as strong on
anime America is a big example of that
like that thrives with a lot that drives
a lot of their views but even then in
the recent years if you look at their
videos for releases a lot of their top
ten videos really are doing it well
especially for the quantity that they're
producing they are not nearly getting
the views that they should be on those
one or two maybe hit it will hit up a
good quantity but that may be out of
like ten or fifteen videos so that's
that's pretty rough so that's the thing
is it's about sort of deed the evolution
of the content and how to continue to
expand that from there so and I mean
the thing is we talk about Curtis
critics he and the eight seals but he
gave it a shot he tried to do something
he's man of the were different people
talked about it so I mean to be honest
people are talking about that's actually
a success you got people talking about
it
see whether it is not good or bad it's
news no news I mean them you're boring
that's not good and that's just business
you know you business you take risks in
this field we take risks you know and
we're fortunate enough to where we can
take that risk without having big
backlashes or implications you know oh
yeah you know if we did something that
somebody didn't like people wouldn't get
a lot of views or they would just plain
out dislike it or say that they don't
like it so then we understand okay we
don't have to do that again so if this
was like a big business endeavor that we
invested millions of dollars in and then
it fails that would be catastrophic
here we spend like a couple hours maybe
maybe a couple bucks here and there and
we go from there we learn our lesson
system
yeah that's a lot of hours that's my
only chain the thing I would change is
like sometimes it's a lot of hours Oh
anywhere nine videos like ten thousand
dollars right
yeah do business is good because it is
really like a private business if you
want to really take it seriously the the
thing is with YouTube you don't have to
get in debt you know borrow a bunch of
money to start the business however you
do really have to have vision to start
from nothing on YouTube and actually
turn it into something because everyone
when you're doing YouTube everyone's
gonna say man you're wasting your time
that's not a real job you're never gonna
get anywhere it's a scam like we've
heard at all right kind of like do
something actually worthwhile do
something that actually is gonna get you
a stable paycheck all that kind of stuff
so it really you do have to have vision
to stick to youtube even when you're not
being successful because no one starts
off being successful right unless you're
already a celebrity or something and
then you translate that to a youtube
channel so yeah it definitely takes
vision you don't have to borrow a lot of
money or anything but you do have to
kind of put in a lot of hours that
you're not necessarily getting paid for
for a long time you got a lot of it the
thing is do you love it yeah exactly
goes and do it love it if you love it
you'll do it because you love it and
that's the thing we don't do it for
money we do it because we love it
otherwise I don't think a lot of people
would do YouTube if they didn't love it
because
like I said it's so much takes so much
to actually get to that point where you
can actually turn it into a business or
anything close to that by the way I
checked right now the one punch man
Japanese website there is no release
date you're talking about like a music
CD you go along with a rap album yeah
it's like icicle wraps so that's gonna
be released um the year but there is no
a season
airdate yet but we're checking that like
you know we do news on this channel
weekly news every Tuesday and also big
any big announcement we do a special
video for it so as soon as we have news
for one punch man if you stay tuned to
this channel you'll be the first to know
uh Anna Mack I watched a final Congrats
I got a dip I love Chris thank you for
joining us very good you should dip all
about the dip play here what do you
moving I almost got here okay I pass the
baton to you why I leave because I have
to pass the baton to me if I'm dipping
but Anna Mac by the way I finished
college and I graduated yesterday
oh oh that's weak gone yeah I so I'm off
to uni September but all about Miriam
attaboy come on man
hi everyone I mean I am slowly starting
to get the British accent and you know
drinking out of tea lately but other
than that I am very happy to go to
university oh god I won't no no mother
that is great yeah do you like that dude
pre-con alright character I'll turn it
persona with that accent like you did in
there at the end
oh that's exciting do it then but for
real I'm about to get to I got head to
the movies
gonna go see cars 3d then all eyes on me
so it's not gonna be as fun as this but
have fun hey you're right you know I had
fun with this you know but I gotta get
back into the groove of things I haven't
done a review in two weeks so now you
gotta watch those movies Tony watch
thank you for joining us Tony everyone
thank you for joining us and like we're
still chillin here but yeah if if you're
new to chill
you don't know that Ren cafes on every
Thursday 5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
you can join us every week um give me
just one second I'm gonna mute my mic
for one second but you guys can continue
just once all right well I want to say I
love cyanide blizzard we do need a talk
homeboy uh way video I'm gonna watch
your video if you dare say bad things
about rim I will never friend you again
god yeah you you will you will like that
video you're gonna hate me don't close
it was a pleasure meeting you all do you
want to say I want to say bro that like
I watch your videos since I was a wee
lad so black
where's my urine on your knee in my in
my eyes bro well thank you I appreciate
that so much time again was it I want to
do a rap with you against a [ __ ]
Briggs and and why are we doing - are we
doing on - are we doing a freestyle rap
are we doing like we write lyrics rap
cuz I'll be honest with you prefer what
would I'm a terrible freestyling okay
then it's better if we do lyrics and we
actually battle against them both and
then in the end we see who is the better
team I think we should do that oh yeah
great video I'm the better I'm the best
there's no me and you are the best they
both suck no no you need to sit down and
be humble my friend
alright yes real like well I'm gonna
rhyme Emilia all night I felt like that
[ __ ] blue rabbit right right you know
bro I think what I ended up like that
take it easy guys drop you - damn good
one is see you say up see you guys yeah
men but cyanide I'm sad to hear you're
gonna be yeah man I'm not like I'm
serious uh not a good slouch ya know I
wanted to drop the news here I've been
I've been trying to get back into it I
was hoping to do so but with my schedule
currently it's just obviously you both
though for producing your channel the
longer it goes the more time it takes
and to be honest actually I really
haven't had the time to produce my my
content the way it's been I've actually
been dipping into more of my
time than I would have normally cared to
and it was actually uh it was last year
I realized it because pause and select
was going to do a top three list and I
realized last year i neve infiniti three
shows i only watch two so i was just
like i don't watch anime anymore really
and it's like i didn't get a chance to
do a lot of that stuff so i wanted to
kind of step back and refocus on a few
things and hopefully do so it doesn't
mean I'm gonna be gone forever I
definitely like to come back but yeah
and unfortunately it's just it's been a
lot difficult to manage everything else
and I've had lost stuff going on dental
work earlier like I'm a mouth has bought
me a bit but I'm like I'm not missing
this video I've already missed the past
few rad cafes I'm not missing 20k
because that's a huge milestone
seriously goes and back you guys
entirely deserve it you guys have been
doing some great work you're fantastic
individuals as well and glad I've gotten
a chance to know both you so yeah
awesome another people yeah thanks a lot
man it means a lot to me like you know I
think you're an awesome guy cyanide I
love your content and I definitely
understand because YouTube to do you to
be really and to do it well you really
gotta spend a lot of time on it and if
you're doing school you got a job you're
doing as well it's impossible thankfully
like goals and I are two of us so
sometimes if one is busier the other one
can pick up the slack and help out but I
totally understand however I do hope you
come back into the game you're always
welcome on rent cafe of course and I do
look forward to seeing more of your
content because I just you know I really
enjoy you as a person you're great guy
and I enjoy your videos your this the
humor everything is awesome and you know
I know everyone loves you
table [ __ ] we all love you here on the
channel the whole community am I ever
gonna see you again cyanide Kyle you
know I'll still be around does not be so
melodramatic
I mean he's leaving so I'm supposed to
do
I know I some goodbyes I know you'll be
okay
right yeah no I'll still I'll still
definitely make time for Rand cafe my
availability may be a little more
sketchy but I'll definitely still make
time for that I just won't be able to
producing for my content because
especially with the new four
I've been using for my videos it takes
more time and as Animax said you know I
especially want to continue to improve
what I do and not regress with that so
to be able to produce a quality product
or at least a competent product I I
would need more time so and but you know
I'll definitely be back in the future I
definitely want to will have to get all
three of you involved in some aspect or
another it's good I look for it will
happen oh yeah man
we're gonna be gonna be a lot of fun
it's gonna be a lot of fun and I hope
that ran cafe as a podcast can grow as
well cuz that way then we can you know
increase our reach as a platform and
spread the word about upcoming project
so that people actually know and get the
word out because yeah I feel like
there's a lot of great stuff going on on
YouTube within our circle of people that
are here on Red Cafe will curl the
awesome wraps that we've been dropping
it's been crazy so I think that yeah
it's it's it's a lot of good stuff is
happening and we just want to keep
working hard and keep growing that
community that's what that's what
matters the most
you guys just need to know that whatever
happens in life I always always love you
guys
like spike said never the best thank you
you guys have now serious cause I don't
[ __ ] laugh at this I'm serious no
well man I feel the same way man the
YouTube friends we made it was like it's
everything else not even considering it
was worth it you know this whole journey
was was worth it and the subs is insane
like it's crazy
yeah shot dose demon wolf shout out to
him great guy great guy the night of
zero on discord right now my goal is to
reach literally 20k just like you guys
and I hope I'll get I will get there
eventually amen
if you stick to the winning team anime
up or if you stick close to us there's
no limit I'm not gonna say things so
copy but you'll get there right you're
getting that's it that's all you
definitely you tell me that I say such
demotivation oh no no that came out
wrong man that's all I meant
but alright
is inspirational you know stick with me
and you'll do good but like don't stick
with me and I'll destroy you you know I
mean no that's [ __ ] up
the me an anima Kurt totally different
personalities
I've met Adam AK when he had like about
I think four thousand subs I think so
Robin even I met him when he had like
six hundred men I'm ed goes and when he
was just born man I gave me my name my
real name I named him you named him goes
on how nice yeah I think oh this has
been a crazy party I really enjoyed this
stream a lot no yeah I exact like a
chill just like appreciation stream yeah
it's like being grateful everybody for
supporting us being grateful I have
missed this I have missed this
incredibly so not trying to suck up I
have genuinely missed this this is been
a blast
yeah for sure and I mean I wish I wish
we could have you more often Sinai cuz
it's always great having you also I wish
Mac and Bryn and Rose could be here but
they're too busy however Red Cafe always
open to all of you guys of course so I
can't wait for more episodes more fun
times we're gonna keep this at it and
hopefully we're gonna have a big ramp if
a panel at anime North next year that's
the that's the dream so we'll see we can
make that happen I wish I can actually
go there move is too far away I don't
actually wanna meet you all on be bar of
the ran cafe that you're gonna have the
panel blah I can go well man there's a
year plan ahead bro plan ahead yeah you
never know in a year's time it's
possible so yeah gianna says she loves
other anime lovers and yeah that's
exactly what we this community year is
all about at anime uproar we love
meeting other anime fans who care and
love the stuff that we care about and
love and just kind of forming a
community so we can try that's what we
love doing streams that's what we love
chatting in discord just you know
creating a community because that's what
it's all about
because at the end of the day you could
be doing anything you could be making
more money you know working some kind of
office job or whatever but you don't
form that kind of community with people
who like the same things you like and
really care passionately about those
things and that is one of the things
that something like YouTube is great for
and that is why we got into this this in
the first place right goes in for the
love for the community like I I like I
said I want to just chime in here like
before when I was in high school and
like I just had random channels before
this one and you know they always get
copyrighted because you're using anime
and I was like making AMD's and stuff
and like I never thought I could
actually make money from this but I just
made videos because I liked it right and
it's insane that this turned out to be
something you can actually make an
occupation on because back then nobody
was making a living off of it so it's
sick that there are anime youtubers now
and you can actually have a job being an
anime youtuber and obviously it's all
thanks to the subscribers in the
community
like it can happen which is amazing yeah
and even it's for fun it's great you
know just being able to meet people and
other things like I'm grateful animatic
reached out to me and it's been a blast
I've been able to meet you him recon so
on and so forth so yeah it's been great
Anna Mac my apologies do I cut you off
there my good man I don't know no
problem at all someone was just Mario
was asking about the discord link yes it
is in the description I'll put it in the
chat as well where you guys check out
always a fun time on this go we have a
big question oh sorry sorry
okay yeah we have on this cord like we
have events like we have karaoke events
we have like anime watching events are
just like voice chats fanfiction
readings like all sorts of fun stuff
it's like a real awesome community there
I love it so yeah be sure to check that
out if you enjoy that kind of thing
where you can chat daily with us on a
daily basis go ahead recon now here's
the big question why did you choose me
you would have chosen why was I the
chosen one to join this like this uh you
know I don't know I think it's just that
you knew Briggs or something and I was
like oh this guy seems
one Oh meanwhile him to rank afraid the
so new bricks process off hey just
because I know Briggs and that's a you
decide ok let's invite this guy he seems
well that's how I found out about you
and then I was like this guy's cool we
should have him on rent okay all right
it's out work with me it's like I
commented on um cuz I was watching the
show Joe cast and then showed you casted
advertise for Rand cafe I had commented
a few times and then BAM it just went
from there you know it's it's the beauty
of it's like an actual cafe you don't
know who's gonna walk in and the more
people hear about the more people that
could potentially come by so yeah it's
just you know I'm glad I was the chosen
one thank you yeah Red Cafe will be our
sitcom one day you know just everyone's
popping in ranting about anime having
zero to hero in the chat what's up bro
he's always supporting the streams who
see Ben he's been here for a long time
appreciate your support bro every
everyone is saying that I'm getting so
cheesed you are a mini about this is
that refund with the fields bro be con
with the field
I don't just happy that you both reach
20 km at the same time just sad that
cyanides going away it's just yeah yeah
a lot of mixed emotions today well you
know it's a lot of mixed emotions yeah
you know to new beginnings to endings
you know everything in between it's it's
all process of life it's all wonderful
things so not too fired up says why was
Ana Mac the first youtuber to notice me
because not sue I notice great people
and great potential in everyone and
that's why I noticed you and you are a
great guy you've been supporting us on
so many videos and streams man and means
a lot to us thank you
not so not to said that will be the
biggest anime youtubers so even so soon
so you know nos who's been supporting us
so much it's insane you look out the
anime man look out yeah pretty soon you
know you were making videos about the
anime man you know a key dearest lost
pause soon they're to be making videos
about you
remember our old skits yes yeah yeah
that was fun that was like when we were
just starting out and we were like oh
what youtubers do we watch let's make
like skits referencing them yeah that
was cool I remembered that stuff by the
way any more ASMR coming up don't tell
me cyanide that you're saying oh I'm
stepping away from you to mean why are
you can open a secret ASMR channel and
make that big money I might actually do
so I the people have asked about to
where I'm actually trying to look into
doing another ASMR video somehow but
some dancing like April oh no I don't
want to wait that long so but it's so
popular like some of these are crazy
like for example I only watch certain
ASMR videos with very very attractive
women doing them like I have a very
selective taste there's like three ASMR
channels that I watch all three very
attractive women I you know I'm not
other stuff not for me cool but it's
very popular man SMR youtubers grow so
fast that's crazy
wait sign I didn't you already do an
ASMR with like oh look like a book and
flipping pages and yes that yeah how did
that video do I still didn't watch it oh
it did okay but I don't know I should
probably try to do something
legitimately but it's I like it kind of
being what it was so no yeah I was
hilarious it was so funny like goes and
you remember when you came into the
house and I was just scream laughing
that almost passed out yeah you were all
sweating and [ __ ] it was weird yeah man
what in cyanide would at the end of that
vide and by the way guys of course
everyone does on wreck of a the links to
their channels are in the description if
you want to check them out I absolutely
encourage you to do so all great peeps
you can check out cyanides ASMR video
you can check out recons top 10 a.m. V's
you can check out goes in goes ends of
videos on this channel but yeah goes
that actually he made videos on YouTube
for youtubers even bought up by Google
right yeah yeah I remember I remember
how mad you were talking about I hate
what YouTube has become because when
Google bought YouTube everything was
getting copyright strikes and stuff for
a while it was crazy yeah cuz we were
just sharing our love for anime like
making a MVS and like you know it was it
was fun and then Google is just like no
copy strike their coffee strike their it
was like damn it
son I'd what are you doing ASMR with
your voice I mean I've never even heard
your your voice I'm so low in you know
what I mean a some more style what are
you doing right now tell it let me hear
can we not want to make any Max sweat
all right
what watches ASMR video I'm not
comfortable listen I like I doubt he's
ever gonna do that I don't think he's
gonna do advice without here to voice
one last time before he goes away he's
not he's not dead he's here young I know
he's not dead listen but no I'm not
comfortable with dudes doing SMR no
thank you
dude whispering in my ear no thank you
uh everyone is starting to ship me in
cyanide now in the well Chris you're
asking it to anus mr you live on Red
Bear you maniac you maniac living
dangerously there
yeah like Haru says impromptu ASMR on
rank of a just like what has happened
one people were complaining that this is
already a sausage fest and now we're
gonna get into ASMR c'mon
so yeah goes then what's next for us bro
just keep working hard keep grinding and
hopefully good things come yeah for sure
again uh very steadily I was showing
goals and the other day like how many
ideas I have for the summer for videos
not just attack on Titan but also for
other anime and for just some like a
general anime related stuff like skits
and
just commentary and stuff so I feel like
even some retro stuff talking about some
70s anime things like that that I want
to talk about eventually so yeah there's
there's gonna be a lot of cool stuff
happening and yeah we hope you guys stay
tuned to the channel and yeah thank you
for the support man has been crazy it's
been crazy I can't even believe like
sometimes I look at like social blade
and I'm like what the hell is happening
man I can't even believe it because you
know you compare just a few weeks ago
our growth rate like we were still
growing but then it's just like bam bam
it's crap hoping to get a million views
in a month that would be cool ya know
yeah if anyone can do it you guys can
yeah we're like eight hundred thousand
substance now so we have like like eight
more days or something you know we just
want to make those pedantic romantic
numbers bro we're trying to hit those
pedantic romantic numbers by the way our
boi DX fan has been growing really fast
to a cyanide let me noticed he is blown
up crazily so I think he's gotten like
in the past two months like 15k
subscribers or something it's been
absurd yeah yeah kiss his wand video on
the steam library
we're steam library are like I don't
know that much about gaming as he does
but that video is over million views
right now so yeah definitely very oles
yeah I was three hundred thousand that's
crazy yeah yeah yeah I swear a million
views now so yea DX fan Touche he's like
he's a good guy though from from what
I've from a lot I've seen even if our
tastes don't match well clearly he saw
that you guys were growing as well and
he's like I can't have them catching up
to me
I gotta pull ahead again yeah we'll see
we'll see though we'll be back we'll be
back
um sell perfect sell says I'm so
beautiful and perfect true well done
well done an America's like is this Yuri
oh nice I don't know you wanna keep
people keep on shipping me inside I was
like okay is this is this urea nice so
am i Yuri ensign
nice Victor I don't know which one's the
Victor I frankly the ha ha ha I mean I
don't know Victor's a tall guy so I
presumed silent taller than me Oh
cyanide I'll tall are you
aah I am 6 foot on the spot
really old we're the same height so as
good I am 5 foot 8 oh you're officially
Victor
oh I picture cyanide as shorter but he's
my height so I picture him as shorter
cuz he has like uh you know very
youthful voice so I picture him as like
a little little Edward Elric Thai food
now that's the thing uh between myself
another friend we feel my friends were
convinced after we met up about like
seven years after we'd seen each other
in high school he was convinced that the
both of us may possibly be vampires so
he's like you guys look the same as you
did in high school what the [ __ ] hahaha
so quoting exactly wrong with you dudes
there is something wrong with you guys
but are we not eyes in the chat what's
up Nana Jana he wants you to be discord
or chat more tonight I'll be in discord
voice chat guys this court leaned on
assumption Anna Mac as Victor which
makes sense yeah because I'm the winner
of everything like you know like no cuz
you just you just look like Victor bro
okay roll ma Victor and a Mac Victor
that's what you mean and no okay I do
not look like Victor yeah I don't know
you're missing it's bigger at all
actually actually you do your hairstyle
definite looks similar to Victor shut up
both who do you think he he base it on
that Oh Mina wait did you ask so you
went to the barber and asked him can
have the haircut exactly like Victor
from Union dice
did you like show them a picture of
Victor while he looks like he said okay
I'll do that
Oh Anna Mac feel our shot
needle you know stop you no no no no
girl for
common you just need to find yourself
your URI man I'm not into URI or yaoi
and you're definitely gonna enjoy em
welcome to the ballroom most likely I'm
not going to enjoy I'll go to the
ballroom I'm not going
welcome to the ballroom I'm sorry give
it a go it's not gonna contain any
[ __ ] URI I'm pretty sure most likely
hopefully by the way guys people saying
I look like Victor I should cosplay as
Victor do you want a really really
heterosexual Victor is that what you
want
I feel like that would crush your dreams
but if that's what you want can I can i
cosplay as you d Oh ed America okay shut
up man okay [ __ ] okay with him are you
into RAM are you into uh what's-her-name
from highschool DxD Reyes rias or are
you a to Victor come on Denise I'm gonna
tell you the truth I'm a fan of beauty
and ice I don't know why I just really
enjoyed the damn show okay man it's
nothing to do with gear just enjoyed the
show it was so good that I'm just gonna
say it was really great I've heard some
respectable critics that I really
appreciate say it's a good show however
others say it's not as good as people
say so I haven't seen it but you know to
each his own some people think that a
lot of good shows that I think are great
are not so great so and they're actually
no respectable reasonable people so I
can't say one punch man for example I
know a lot of people who think the joke
gets old fast they don't like it and I
personally love one punch man so that's
a good example of that stole maka who
has great taste in some aspects doesn't
like Cowboy Bebop
like what just yeah it's crazy the world
is a messed up place by the way cell is
talking about Dragon Ball super leaks
fake dragon ball super leaks I actually
don't want Dragon Ball super however it
goes
doesn't he's caught up on it so both if
you wanna do you know anything about
this no okay that is all right here hi I
haven't been watching Dragon Ball super
I have to say I did I did like Dragon
Ball Z back in the day but I haven't
watch Dragon Ball super just not my cup
of tea a little too childish for me but
goes and does seem to enjoy it and
watched it yeah my best friend uh me i
watch with my best friend and we we love
talking about it
red haired girls are always the best
anime man you know I have to say else a
lot of most of the girls I love our
redheads
yohko Colin um who else was it rias an
auto semi oh it wasn't restore me but it
was it was I like um you can't you don't
even know her room uh Haruki she's
redhead uh there was someone else there
was someone else
I can't think now but I also love from
quote yes I love the letter everyone
knows that she's not a redhead but like
yeah a lot of the girls that I like from
anime and I'm not being redheads I
didn't notice until people ask me who
would be like in your harem and I'm like
man my arm would be like 80% redheads
Shoshanna from uh was the anime Shakugan
no Shana
um she is Sakura from surah so she knows
a [ __ ] and Mia from mas from su Mei Yoko
um heirs are from Fairy Tail yes
heirs I like her - yeah she's already
yeah Lilith from Trinity 7 you can't
deny her she's a she's a hottie who yes
I think I think I think definitely
redheads an anime yeah redheads I'm like
very interesting period I was gonna top
everyone goes end what are your what are
your favorite girls in anime what hair
color do they tend to be there's no rule
for it it's just like the cutest one
like Nagisa
Holmes in philosophy you know it's my my
hair consists of a variety of hair
colors I don't discriminate
rather than your colors Ian sign I are
on the same page no it's true I don't
discriminate I just tend to like that to
me I'm thinking about it you have to
defend yourself
no this Granicus up they were two girls
oh yeah
jirô the hero says Celestia from
recreate errs yeah oh yeah yeah the red
one that's a good one as well yeah I'm
enjoying recreate errs I'm watching it
as it's coming on and I'm really
enjoying it I do want to make a video on
recreated as well eventually and I would
be out and hopefully while it's still
well it's still out and not like five
years later no item Jim what are you
doing
why don't you do explained honoree
creators because there's a bunch of
theories you know talking about
everything within the show so why don't
you both come up with explain videos
yeah like I haven't been watching it but
I'm actually definitely jump on that
know what the thing is you can make
explain videos right as you know until
the twelfth episode airs because it
might answer all the questions and you
might be wrong no you can still make
series looking but look at geekdom 101
like he talks about what's gonna happen
next episode like every everyday just
try come up with theories it's a really
really smart thing to do I would say
that like I said just to talk this
season ends and there's a big
cliffhanger or something and I have a
theory on it I'll do it but I won't try
to just like come up with these crazy
ass theories and it's like yo bro four
days later it was proven wrong like I
don't wanna like I said I'll just jump
on hyped rains without knowing what I'm
doing I want to actually produce quality
content Oh like I feel like you're
you're that's stupid but okay
illegally you can definitely produce
quality content like but whatever I know
I did say that redhead girls are the
best
but what if M was red haired imagine
that bro Ram is better than Ram no no
imagine of remnant was red hair and how
awesome would that be
she was a redhead clam of anime then she
would pop most likely top every [ __ ]
waifu because she's blue head then no
not really
but she's still gorgeous
care but if you guys have ideas about
recreated videos that we would like to
see and if I like the ideas and I would
be passionate about them let me know
dearly hero says comparing re creators
and fate/stay night that's an
interesting concept because it's a
similar idea of magical creatures coming
into the real world and fighting each
other
my magical characters with powers right
so that is that is a cool idea so that's
one example actually actually might do
that write that [ __ ] down rivers at work
here so how's everyone doing today good
recon just celebrating like I I didn't
sleep a lot because I was working on the
video that we posted today so I took a
nap before this rain cafe thing but I
could have missed the 20,000 subs
special yeah and I think the only
important for goes on to be here because
like I said he doesn't come to an cafe
often but this is like a special one and
just yeah you gotta be here ah
so what's next
100,000 bro heard a thousand yeah 30 40
50 a year of your going on for 50 right
now that's your next goal which is
rolling a 50 great is that the road that
connects goal yeah I would say that's
the next goal which is halfway towards
your big goal hundred K I don't say that
yeah that's true yeah you gotta
celebrate two little things like you
know get thirty thousand we're gonna be
like look yeah and but just like it's
not even about you know the sub count
it's about the community to me it's
inside a we're hearing like we have to
say man like people actually list them
that's what I love yeah like people
actually want to hang out with us come
to the tags that's fine explain you know
talk talk to us give us ideas for videos
I'll talk to us about theories Chad with
us on discord watch our videos comment
on them like them share them like that's
that's so amazing whether it's a
thousand people doing it
hundred thousand it's still crazy and
awesome and just humbly experiencing
where else in the world are you going to
find that kind of you know support and
connection as an academic as someone who
finished
you know grad school and stuff academics
they publish academic papers they have
to publish that to get jobs promotions
and those papers might be right about
like ten people like ten other people
with paid PhDs and they're like oh [ __ ]
I published this in this journal and
like ten people read it
meanwhile on YouTube you can make a
video and get fifty thousand use in one
day fifty thousand people interacting
with you watching your video hearing
what you have to say so it's like crazy
good God was like the only reason I'm
here is to hear you guys bragging about
your subs for not bragging
we're being grateful man and this is a
lot of us just thanking you guys yeah I
mean spreads about celebrating those
milestones not forgetting clearly you're
not here to listen when goes and earlier
talked about their humble beginnings and
upstarts in reminiscing as well and I
remember journey I wanted to mention
this I remember like for wait wait wait
I remember there was this one time where
literally I was it was like my one of my
first YouTube accounts and I had 30 subs
and I was like oh man like 30 people sub
that was like I was so so cycler you
can't even believe and everyone that
went up I was like like elated so this
is this is amazing this is unreal yeah
and it's a PewDiePie talks when he still
has the video of him when he got like a
special for a hundred subs and he talks
about how happy was that a hundred
people were watching him and stuff and
yeah it's true it's crazy like you know
where else in real life are you gonna
have so many people actually caring
about what you do you know watching you
do anything play a sport or do anything
like where unless you're a professional
athlete who's going to care that much
about what you do and yet here on
YouTube people doing it's really a great
platform like I said with all its faults
it's a great platform but
sign I just want to say you said that we
were reminiscing Anna Magdalene
reminisce he Amelia mrs. OH
oh [ __ ] you ha ha bye granny I agree
well robot
how about reminisces what you [ __ ] it
what was the word again that you said
cyanide
Amelia nYSSA's I said that because he
said reminisce and I said no I only knew
you yes oh it was better it's better if
it's reminisce not emelius Oh God give
it up recon I want Amelia I wanted
Amelia best girl everyone knows it
no Bremer's best girl pretty sure
everyone in the chat agrees with me no
one the child is except soul knocking on
boo yes he on booze already in there
with hashtag round best girl so
predictable omelette no predictable I
know Julia so Makaha Emilia forum on the
SCOTUS that's also a good choice Android
a lot of zeros one says Ram is better
girl and I agree that Ram is definitely
gonna to run Ram RAM [ __ ] no offense to
the RAM lovers vago about that REM I'm
all about that rim bro you got I'm all
about rod looking forward to black
credit guys rap video man flaming dragon
what's up man he says a hobbit on the
storm says best redhead is Spice and
Wolf a hollow hollow from spice of all I
don't know man I feel like she's an
orange head rather than a redhead yeah
it's more of an orange e color
so yeah like yeah you'll read my enemy
orange is different than red right like
you know you all sorts of hair colors
and orange is definite different on rent
so Marcus says cetera is best girl soul
maka likes yonder a yonder yeah if
anyone is a yonder its Adela
and what's her name
the girl from the like the first arc
that the assassin oh god what's her name
yo Nate Nate says congratulations fellas
yo it's Nate hey what's up man one of my
few IRL friends right there Nate was
going on
nice how's Florida treating you we
actually have black critic guy one of
our regular guests here he's also in
Florida he's around the Orlando area I
believe for a guy says he hates Ken and
never wants the company told he wants to
come he totally wanted to be at anime
north
[ __ ] hell so though you're freaking I
smashed 18 yes Elsa imperialist opinions
yes that's Elsa Elsa's the yandere girl
from the first arc how did I not
remember that I should just think of
frozen ride Fuu has to pass out see Ryan
thank incoming woo yeah I think we
should end up wrapping it up too man we
gotta eat yeah we got a heat man we got
to eat that street slang for we gotta
make that money get a hustle
nobody L we got up we got to wrap it up
thank you everyone for showing up for
the special rad cafe we're gonna
continue the party on discord tonight
just having a great time and partying
and thank cyanide for being back here
always you're always welcome and I get
that you're busy but feel free to get in
touch anytime we love you pleasures all
mine think you'll always be our tables
cuz I nod Oh
feel the love think you feel it but I
love them more though there's so much
love in this community but he's my sign
I don't do not a competition bro and
thus the reconyx cyanide parents start
up again
you're a cool man
it's never too late for zero cool no one
else will get that reference but that's
okay
all right everybody um recon as well
thank you for coming ah check out guys
check out recon check out sign on there
links are in the description same thing
with black credit guy with all day
animate great beeps great youtubers
check them out links in the description
disk or link is also in the description
if you want to join with us on a daily
basis chatting having fun and yeah goes
and anything else you want to say to the
people before we wrap it up yeah thank
you guys so much for not only watching
our videos but showing up to these live
streams and supporting us and like all
the ways you do this could not be
possible without you guys and thanks so
much we're living the dream yeah I'm
gonna be in voice chat on discord around
8 or 9 something like that for sure goes
in I don't know if you'll have time cuz
he's working out on these videos but I
will be there also this Saturday lookout
for review of the episode of the final
season finale of the attack on Titan
episode also I'm going to have a special
video regarding attack on Titan I'm not
gonna reveal anything but it's gonna be
fun so look out for that and we're
having a special twitch party on
Saturday night at 8 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time or we're just going to be
talking like getting um having fun
playing party games talking about the
attack 9 season finale just kind of
hanging out so if you're on Twitch if
you want to hang out with us we're there
as well link in the description you can
see all our social media in the
description so come and join us there as
well it's gonna be fun and of course on
this cord we always let you know when
there are streams and stuff going on so
if you're on this cord we're gonna send
you notifications and you're gonna know
when we're live on Twitch or on YouTube
or anywhere else where we are at the
time so maka has his bourbon ready
classy guy classy guy this I'm excited
nice alright thanks again guys for
joining us everyone in the chat everyone
who's watching live and after
burns all our guests who came here and
goes and of course we are very grateful
very proud to be where we are and until
next time what is powerful
Floyd I love you all love you all oh
[Laughter]
okay oh so soggy piece carboys shin Paco